welcome to this video playing grand
master Robert husky yeah it's nice
sometimes to have a name where you
directly identify who this is it is a GM
from the United States okay so we're
going to get a new missile here with
Nadia 3 and g3 oh that's not very usual
this capture hmm yeah I wonder if 94 is
still an option here I can normally play
probably yeah I like this kind of this
kind of position trying to trying to
keep my dark squared bishop in their
structure he has 95 ideas though hmm do
I go age 6 that's very slow okay I still
do it
I wanted this set up this is why oh and
age six there I could have played Bishop
e7 to cover G 595 would provoke g6 which
I really don't want to play ok so here
proudly Knight e5 hmm might be tricky
and see white always has pressure and
this type of position for his bad policy
has the D&B file or oakland i have to be
quite um yeah quite precise as black to
not allow some kind of bind on the dark
square cm something when if he ever gets
the pawn to c5 for example it would be
very very problematic ok like g6 now
yeah I guess we should be 76 alyssa is
an idea for developing with tempo him
maybe but what's the idea of Queen a
form Bishop a three-year I don't really
get the idea so Bishop d7 to c6 was my
initial idea getting stuff traded yeah I
don't think it's a bad idea take the
tags with this decent i can take five
maybe I wonder if that was a good a good
move water
yeah I think this is surprisingly okay i
think the night takes be takes Bishop
takes rupee aid as a 10 point then
Queenie of six is very decent public I
didn't really plan that beforehand but
it is quite okay so he avoids that yeah
probably with good good reason um c 6
Mia it's a possible weakness
yeah that's opposite colored bishops
okay so yeah I don't want to give the
pawn just yet my ideas CIF 584 if he
lets me but maybe I took the wrong look
there I am that's Bette's very much
possible yeah rooked is so it's not too
great but I think if he really wants to
play rock d 7 i'm not don't minding that
much he winces six but i'm not sure how
much this really offers right
ok so like would be six Queen 85 as idea
two
I'm not really sure if he has anything
here in this position that's kind of
dull think you will just go back to a
for now problem is that this opposite
colored bishops are always always some
yeah drawing drawing factor
I have no particular a DN this position
have to admit him just sitting around
maybe I should have played h5 g6 but
okay it's not a big deal he might play
age 5 and I should have I should have
really played age 5 myself it would have
been a little bit a little bit more
precise nothing serious but it would
have been a little bit more precise
definitely
taking a bit too long him
time warning
I still think there's not much going on
there
so I got 11 rook traded I'm covering my
weakness there
oh I didn't get that idea it's bad
should have seen it
what is the idea their queen of three
young
oh no no Queen d1 just a stupid idea i
didn't i didn't really see check check
yeah that was completely unnecessary
loss out of nothing check check
black4 fits on time yeah I was
completely unnecessary he has absolute
absolutely nothing going on in this
position I killed myself him by really
playing in a stupid way it's never ever
happening anything just have to see that
there's Queen D 1 yeah um in fact if I
go f5 here probably not even worse
anymore I just thought I can do that in
any case yeah that's the assessment I
just go here see I'm not even worse not
at all he's playing without the bishop
there no problem whatsoever there's
nothing going on in this position never
was i just have to prevent Queen D 1
Jeff Cook g7 whatever I have this this
kind of idea here black wins even which
is not necessary of course I just think
it there's nothing going on I think it's
just about equal there's no reason why I
should be should be better not much at
least i think it's it's just just equal
for a very long time but yeah after
Queen d1 the way I plated it got tricky
and it was much easier if I would have
avoided his age five yeah this is a bad
idea now it gets kind of tricky yeah
comp wants to play a five but that's not
not very human the ante I'm chows down
I'm toast Queen a six is still ok but
now that that skip that gets very tricky
I was thinking of this gets ok probably
I can play this passive defense IAM even
that is it wrong yeah that was strong of
course it is really badly also a bit too
passively I have this f5 idea I should
have I mean I saw that the idea is there
but I thought I can't play it like
whenever I want and I didn't ask myself
the question what the move route did to
is actually doing I mean if I really
fail to see anything I can just do this
and I'm still not not not losing ever ok
I can take a 7 i'm sorry i don't give up
a 7 that's not a good idea but losing c6
i just put the bishop 1c5 and that's it
yeah there's nothing going on I have
five is strong though if I can really
shut out his bishop this is more like
black doing something then then why
doing something but now that wasn't that
wasn't good yeah I didn't really spot
that quickie one is coming ok well
thanks for watching